thanks a lot for introducing us
um yeah Welcome to our talk
um we're very honored to have one of the
first Slots of this conference so we
somehow introduced this year's pycons
which made us very very glad
um yeah we're happy to share Apache
stream perhaps with you and especially
Apache stream pipes for python which is
a new major
which is a new
um which is a new major feature of
Apache stream pipes can you hear me now
clearly okay great
um yeah and we want to show you how
Apache stream pipes kickstarts your
handling of iot data and enables you to
directly start with the fun part
um yeah
so we have prepared a short slide about
us a lot of information have already
been mentioned but since some people are
joining still I will just have the short
introduction
um yeah my name is Tim I'm working as a
data engineer at innovex and more than
that I'm also actively contributing to
Apache stream pipes I'm also part of the
PMC which stands for program management
committee which can somehow be compared
to the core maintainer team around
Apache stream paths
I came across with stream pipes during
my time at University and are now I
think for two or up to three years
contributing to to stream pipes and I'm
very happy to share this talk today with
Sven
hello my name is Sven I'm a student for
artificial intelligence at the
University in Offenburg and I'm also a
working student at white fabric AI I'm a
committer for the Apache stream pipes
project and I worked on the python
library that we will show you later
all right but very important to mention
here is that stream pipes is not about
only us too so we are only holding this
talk on behalf of these dream pipes uh
Community Committee community and in
total we are around let's um probably 25
committers across several countries and
even continents
okay so much about us let's start with
the actual talk
um if you remember last autumn and
winter and maybe even summer energy has
been a huge topic during the world and
especially Europe and Germany
I have brought you some newspaper
articles that just very drastically show
what what um the fears were during the
time luckily things didn't turn out that
bad like this media articles have
implied but we are still facing an
energy crisis and we realized that
especially Germany has a need to
modernize in how we produce and consume
energy especially in the heating
technology
um so one one approach of one technology
that is recently very widely and also
actively discussed this this one I
brought here it's a heat pump
um
and yes that's probably one way
um people can modernize their energy
prediction in yeah in the upcoming years
and I think what's also changed besides
more focusing on new technologies is
also the willingness to measure one's
energy consumption and also having more
insights in how we consume energy and
how we efficient we are in this and
these were also some thoughts that Sven
and his family had and they also
invested in such a heat pump
and not ever interested in how this heat
pump actually performs and when it's
most efficient
so luckily the most modern industry
devices have somehow an interface to
extract data and this is also the case
for the seat pump so they offer modbus
as a protocol to to get data from it so
that's pretty cool they thought so let's
build an appealing dashboard
and the next step is to have a look at
modbus so modbus was invented in 1979
it's very old
industry protocol for communication
between programmable ultimate logic
controllers so that are electronic units
that are inside every larger industrial
industrial product
supports only four type of data or
objects two of them are represented only
by one bit so you can only store Boolean
values in it and the other twos allow
you to store 16-bit which are again
smaller integers
um
and you have also to take care about the
addresses and all the registers so you
have to exactly know where you stored
your data and where you can get them
from
so to be honest this does not really
sound really fun or convenient to work
with and that's exactly the place where
patchy stream pipes come in so Apache
stream pipes is an open source
industrial iot toolbox that one enables
non-technicial users to connect analyze
and exploit iot data streams and we're
not only focusing non-technical users
but also persons who are people who
doesn't like to get involved in all
these iot protocol stuff and all the
pitfalls they they have
as streampipes is a project of the
Apache foundation and we have been
graduated to top level projects a month
ago
um yeah and we have recently launched
version 0.91.0 which as I already
mentioned mainly includes our python
support
stream pipes at the core follows an
event-driven approach so every data
point in science three times is
represented as an event and therefore
um yeah shared and
processed figuring
um during stream pipes
as a next step I just want to share some
of our core features with you and give
you a quick walk through to through them
the first one is stream pipes connect
that's exactly the place when you just
want to adapt a data source for the
first time connect is somehow a
Marketplace for all the adapters we have
in place in stream pipes it allows you
to quickly connect industrial data
sources in real time we have around 20
adapters currently that we support
and we also allow you to apply some
pre-pressing rules for data
harmonization directly at this point so
for example if you want to transform a
data point in its unit of measurement
and we also demonstrate you how this
works in our demo later on
the next step is you have now your data
within stream pipes and you probably
want to somehow manipulate them or
process them and share them at other
places so therefore we have the pipeline
editor where you can Define your data
pipelines within an interactive UI
and we have plenty of
predefined data processing
data processes they are currently around
100 I guess and they're ranging from
simple threshold or alerting processes
up to embedding AI models or more
complex stuff
we also offer an SDK so that you can
write your own processing elements
currently this is only possible in Java
but we're planning to add this feature
to our python integration as well
and if you now have your data in the
shape you want we have two ways to
actually present them in stream pipes
the first one is a live dashboard this
just allows you to easily visualize some
live metrics and kpis with some
pre-defined widgets that allow you to
easily show your data in a Gorge or as a
simple line chart
and a second data analysis tool we offer
is the data Explorer which is somehow a
bit more advanced so this allows you
also to analyze your data in a
historical representation and this
offers more extensive features to find
correlations in your data to just create
more appealing and also more advanced
plots
all right now I have show I've shown you
the exact features very in a more
detailed fashion and now I want to have
a look at how stream pipes look in an
end-to-end
um
in an end-to-end manner
at the left hand side we already start
with some data sources right and usually
they're heterogeneous for in this case
we have some opcua data and mqtt device
and for example a modbus device like the
heat pump I've just mentioned
we then use streampipes connect to
connect all of the data sources we can
then combine them in our in our
pipelines and enrich them transform them
and manipulate the data in any form
within stream pipes data is handled in
in two ways so you can either persist
them in our time series database or as
long as you process them as Live Events
we do this via our message Brokers where
we also support multiple ones
um if the data is now in that shape it
um as you as you like it to have we have
three different options of how you can
interact with your data the first one is
the graphical user interface which I
have just shared with you so the
pipeline editor the live dashboard and
the data Explorer
and then you can also programmatically
interact with the data and that's what
we mainly show you today so we have for
longer already in Java SDK but now we
also have a python SDK and this is what
our what the second half of the talk
will mainly be about
and an important aspect always is also
you can easily share your data with
external third-party systems so be it
for example Kafka rocket mq iotdb or
other databases like postgresql whatever
you can imagine
all right this already brings us to our
first demo
um
so I would show you the example of the
heat pump I've already mentioned of
course we cannot directly
ingest the data from the actual heat
pump but we have brought you a little
simulator that just simulates the modbus
device
showing the the
um yeah that contains real data of the
heat pump of Swan's family
yeah yeah
um
all right so let me just switch my
screening
okay yeah that's no Apache stream
perhaps and I will now show you how you
easily how you can
um get the data from the mod boost
device with into stream types
as I already said
we have this connect module maybe I'll
just make it a bit larger so that you
can better read it
um and we will now create a new adapter
now we can see a subset of all the
adapters that are available and in our
case we want to integrate data from a
modbus device so that's why we choose
the modbus
adapter and now the only information I
need to provide is the address where the
modbus device is available
in our case this is just the localhost
within a Docker container
then the port where it is available it's
an archives 5502 and then I need the ID
of the device which is in our case Zero
and then I need to add for modbus all
the data that I want to get from it and
in our case it's
um
how was the name sorry
it was the actual hot temple uh hot
water temperature for actual temperature
of water
sorry about that
water okay then I need to provide this
address which uh which is what I already
mentioned and uh simple selector
register so usually for example for the
heat pump or Swan
um it is then described the manual where
you can find the data so this should
then be easily easy to fill up for you
as I already said stream pipes is fully
event based that means every data point
always needs some timestamp this data
source does not provide a timestamp yet
that's why we add one
um within stream pipes
and then we just give it a name
in this case it's heat pump modbus
and then we also can select here that
data is directly stored within the
stream pipe's internal data Lake this
allows it then to easily view them in
the data Explorer which I will show you
later
and then you can already start adapter
and here you can then okay I forgot one
point damn
um so what was the last year only to
store integers right and usually for
example for temperatures they are not
integers their float values and
um that's why you see here 459 because
we have multiplied it by 10 and then you
need to this is a simple trick you
already do in modbus right so you
multiply values by for example 10 or 100
or whatever and then redo the
transformation within your data analysis
platform or in this case stream pipes
and you can simply
at the transformation rule when you
created the adapter that's the aspect I
forgot about I'm very sorry about this
nevertheless I can now show you how you
can now analyze the data
um
data is now flowing into stream pipes
and we can now create
um
so here you can now select the proper
data source that's the one I've just
created
and then we can also select a type of
visualization I think in this case the
time series is the most easiest one
um
and then you get directly created a nice
chart here
um where you can select the time window
you want to you want to see and yeah so
you can just have a view on the actual
temperature that your device
is sending
as I said I'm a bit sorry that I missed
this data manipulation part but
um yeah
all right so then let's get back to our
slides
and now it's when we'll talk tell you a
bit more about the python part
thank you Tim I will now continue with
our stream pipes python library and I
think our demo showed how easy it is to
connect and to store data with stream
pipes but we wanted to combine it with
python for the data analytics part and
therefore created stream pipes python
our motivation was to address the
amazing data's analytics and data
science Community to benefit from the
already existing python libraries
now let's take a look at some basic
information about streampipes python it
was freshly released with the new stream
pipes version and you can easily install
it via Pi Pi you can just type in PIP
install stream pipes and then everything
will be installed we also working on a
condo Forge package and this will follow
soon
for more information you can have a look
at our documentation where you can find
some tutorials and code explanations
now let's take a look at the features of
stream pipes python it contains two
basic features which is the client and
the function the client interacts with
the stream pipes API and there you can
get data from databases and get data
like The Meta information or the data
stored in our time series databases
it allows to interact with the API as I
already said and it connects to a
running stream pipes instant the second
feature are the stream pipes function
they are there to interact with the live
data from the stream pipe status streams
and they are a lightweight processing
element
they only exist at runtime and they
allow to customly and yeah add
functionalities that you want so you can
manipulate the live data with the
functions and there are some built-in
features like an easy integration for
online machine learning for the River
Library
now let's have a closer look at the
architecture of the client so the client
interacts with the stream pipes API
which is in rest API
and uses different endpoints to
communicate with this API
and and it also provides different
endpoints for different resources so
there's one endpoint for the data Lake
measures and one for the data streams
then you can get the data by either
using the All method which will provide
you with all resources of this time and
this also supports the slicing indexing
and looping operators
on the other hand you can get a single
resource by providing the idea of this
resource and then you can get just a
single resource after you got the data
you can also um represent it yeah in
different ways so there's a
representation as a pandas data frame as
a dictionary or as a road chase
now let's see an example how it looks in
the code and there you can configure
your client
um
you can add so the username and API key
but I will show this more detailed in
our second demo and then you can
configure some things like the host
address and the port
and after that you can create a client
with these configurations and then get
the data as I showed before
you can also see the tutorial section of
our documentation if you want to try it
out yourself and want to get more
informations
now let's move on with the architecture
of the function they don't only interact
with the stream pipes API but also with
the messaging layer of stream pipes and
the messaging layer uses different
Brokers to broadcast the live messages
between different components of stream
pipes
so therefore we have the function
Handler that interacts with that and it
internally uses as the stream pipes
client to interact with the API
and in this case it particular gets the
meta information about some data streams
which is used to connect to them after
that you can register different
functions that you want we also have a
function through where you can use some
predefined functions like a live
printing function of the data or a
function to integrate online machine
learning models
and you can create your own function and
yeah add some functionality that you
want
and the final part are the Brokers they
communicate with the messaging layer and
they make sure that every function get
the right data from the right data
stream and yeah make sure that
everything works the right way
now let's see this in life and I will
show you how you can do this in a second
demo
so this demo will show you how you can
get your data from a stream pipes data
Lake into Python and it also shows how
you can subscribe to live data from a
streampipe data stream but first of all
we have to create a client
and therefore we import all necessary
modules
and then you can
set the environment variables for the
user and for the API key I will quickly
show you how you can get your API key in
stream pipes therefore we go back to
stream pipes and then the top right
you can go to your profile
then go to API
enter a name for your RP key
and then simply create it after that you
can copy your API key
and insert it
into your notebook
after that you can create the
configuration for the client so here you
load the environment variables and set
the host address and the port
and then we can create the client
we will quickly test if everything works
by using the describe method
and as you can see everything works fine
you can see that we successfully
connected to stream pipes and that we
have two data like meshes and two data
streams available
we can also have a closer look at the
data Lake measures
and here we use the
API for the data Lake measure and want
to show all of the data in appendix
representation so that's exactly the
architecture as I showed before
and here you can see we have our
um data Lake that we created
and created in this first demo which is
here the modbus
um heat pump and we have another data
Lake where we already stored all data
before and we want to get this data now
so now we can simply extract the data
from the data Lake
and yeah use
and the get method and we can simply
insert the identifier that we can see
here
to import the data
I have also do some pre-processing for
the daytime which we will use for later
data analytics
and as you can see we now get a pandas
data frame where we have different
values of the heat pump like some
temperature values or the power
consumption of the heat pump
and we can also customize this request
and we can add yeah different options
like a limit how many data points we
want and we can also select some columns
so here we select different columns that
contains the temperature value
and it's also possible to configure and
start and end date for this data and
here I get this data and show it with
the plotly library
and now you can see that we get the
different temperature as a plot but
before before we have a closer look at
this I first want to give you some basic
understanding of the data so we have our
heating pump right here right
um and the heating pump heats up the
water and this water is used to either
um heat up the hot water tank or the
buffer tank which is used for the
heating circuit and so here the water
gets heated through some heating coils
and then goes through the heating
circuit where it goes through different
radiators to heat up your room
so now let's go back here you can see
the different temperatures so in blue
there's the outside temperature and on
top you can see that actual temperature
and the target temperature for the hot
water and be loaded that's the same for
the heating circuit and if we have a
closer look here oh
first
worry
that's the wrong one
oh sorry yeah that's correct so here we
can see the the target temperature of
the hot water variates between
um different yeah times of the day and
here you can see how the hot water gets
heated up by the heat pump and after it
slowly
gets colder and there are sometimes some
huge drops in the temperature and that's
probably when somebody had a shower and
used a lot of hot water at once
and now we want to have a closer look at
the
efficiency of our heat pump therefore
you we need to know how we can calculate
it
so the efficiency is just the heat
output Port which is generated by the
heat pump to heat up these two tanks
divided by the car power consumption
that the heat pump uses as electrical
energy
and yeah we can calculate this this
efficiency in
um pilot on the right now therefore when
we create a first calculate the total
produced in energy in form of heat but
every day and create a new column for
the day and group by this day after that
we can add the heating energy and the
hot water energy together and plot the
results and here you can see the total
power consumption for every day
for this time range
and we can exactly do the same
for the consumed power where we just
um yeah add the power consumption for
the heating circuit together with the
power consumption of the hot water we
will also plot this and here you can see
how it looks like with this bar chart
and with these two values we can now
um calculate the efficiency of the heat
pump and we just use the formula that I
showed before so we
take the Heat and divide it by the
consumed power and then we get our
efficiency and we also want to compare
the efficiency with the outside
temperature at the corresponding days
and therefore create a new column where
we um yeah insert the mean temperature
for this day and that's just some code
for the plotting I won't go into detail
here
and as you can see we now get our
efficiency in the with the blue bars
which reaches from about three to six
which means that the heat pump produces
three to six times of the energy that it
consumed and it yeah as you can see they
are very efficient and which makes them
so environment friendly
and as you can see there's this also a
strong correlation between the um
temperature and the efficiency and we
want to have a closer look at this in
another
um data analysis therefore we can
calculate our efficiency by using pandas
and can also plot these two values
together in an um
the scatter plot and as you can see
there's a really high correlation
between these two values with about
0.8 and there's a clear Trend that it
how it gets the more efficient the heat
pump works
now at our next step is to get the live
data from stream pipes and therefore we
want to look at
the available data streams and we
yeah just use the structure that I
showed so we use the data stream API get
all data streams and convert it to a
pandas data frame and as you can see
there are the two different data streams
the one we created and the one we used
for to get all data we will now connect
to the modbus
um
yeah data stream and therefore copy this
element ID
and then we want to create a function to
get this data therefore we need to
implement the four following methods the
first one is this then required stream
IDs where we will insert our copied
stream ID then there's an on service
started method which gets called when
the function gets started and here you
can create
we will create a dictionary to save all
the data and print out that the function
get started the most important function
is the only wind method and it's called
whenever a new event arrives arrives and
there we will save all the live data in
our dictionary and we will also create a
live plot for this data and the final
method is the on service Dot and there
we will just print out that our function
got stopped here you can see exactly
what I told you in code I won't go into
detail here but you can find this
notebook in a GitHub repository if you
want to take have a closer look at this
there's just one extra thing you are you
have to know we can yeah set the column
we want to plot for this live plot
function and then it will plot this data
live
so let's move on
we can now create our live plot
therefore we need another environment
variable where we tell where the host is
and after that we can initialize the
registration where we can register our
function which is the live plot function
I defined before and there we want to
plot the actual temperature of the hot
water
and then we can create the function
Handler that handles all the data and we
can initialize it
oh that's bad and I'm sorry I think we
mixed up the name
because then we okay so I think so the
problem is here we we have chosen a
different name for for the actual
um column I guess so that's why why it's
not working I think um out of time we
have to skip a not very sorry about it
um but what you what you now would see
here is the live interaction
um so you would now see a live plot
um I'm sorry about that I will
quickly drive like it is very good if
not we will just stop it
and yeah
oh I actually yeah I think it's a
different mistake
um I'm sorry I know it right now it's a
stupid mistake but I just forgot to
insert the actual ideas I'm sorry about
this
so now everything should work I hope so
oh yeah okay okay I'm sorry that's the
bad thing about life demos I'm yeah
really sorry and yeah you could if it
would work then easily disconnect this
function
so that's all I wanted to show you for
this demo and and there's a lot more you
could do
um so you could
um use the online machine learning
functionality to get some more um
information about the data you could
easily create notification with stream
pipes and you could also use this data
to optimize your heat pump by changing
configurations and then monitor the
changes of the efficiency
all right so I think this pretty well
highlights um suspense showed some
really powerful tools of how you can
analyze data in Python and that's just
the interface we we want to address
right so we want to have stream pipes as
a tool which allows you to easily
um
to easily get access to to data from
industrial context and then use the
power of python to create amazing
results of it so that's already the main
part of our talk
um we now somehow need a bit of your
help so we love your support if you're
interested in contributing in stream
pipes we're open to that otherwise maybe
just give it a try provide us some
feedback could be either positive or
negative we're happy about both
um if you like it it's always great if
you spread the word and if you have some
interesting use cases um you want to
share with us or The Wider Community it
would also be great if you just approach
us and then we can maybe think about a
blog post or some blog post or something
else
if you want to to talk about stream
pipes later than this talk um we're
happy to to welcome you at our Innova
extend which is just directly across the
food area and I will be there from time
to time and if not my colleagues will
surely approach us and as Sven already
mentioned we have created a GitHub
repository where you can just find the
whole demo and all the things you need
to reproduce it so if you're interested
in give it a give it a shot then you can
go here
then my last words will be thank you a
lot for your attention and your interest
and enjoy the conference
well thank you very much team thank you
very much Sven I think it was a very
nice uh an interesting presentation
um if you want to ask any questions
please go to slido
um they are the code it's
pycon d e Pi data 23 I think the QR code
is also outside
and there are some questions already so
I will ask you questions
and so the first one is how can you
extend shrimp pipes with connectors for
additional custom protocols
that's rather easy so similar to
pipeline elements we also offer an SDK
to easily create your own adapter for
for stream pipes and this is currently
also only possible in Java but there are
is I would say an extensive extensive
documentation and also some code
generation around so that you only need
to implement the stuff that matters for
your connector and not all the
boilerplate that is required by stream
pipes cool
and our question is is there a query
language for the data lakes in the
python SDK that supports time-based
aggregation something like Flex for
inflex DB
yeah so currently we stored data
internally in uh in flag enough influx
database and we make it extensible to
the other side via the rest API So
currently it's not possible to directly
query data via query language but via
the rest API which then allows you to
handle the data within the python
environment and use pandas or polas or
whatever you want want to use
and our question is what does the
deployment model look like for stream
pipes
so stream pipes is a microservice based
tool so we have a couple of Docker
images in place and then you're able to
start stream pipe simply with Docker
compose that's the most convenient and
easiest deployment solution and in case
you want to actually work on Apache
stream pipe stand dcli is probably more
the way you want to go and if you want
to use stream pipes in a more mature way
we also have a Helm chart in place so
that you can easily deploy stream pipes
within a kubernetes setup okay
thank you there are two more questions
one is can timestamps be defined as part
of the parameter list Okay so
probably the question is about when I
query the data from from the API I'm
sure it can since we have an event based
streamer and we always talk about time
series The timestamp is always per
default
um
trans transmitted and you will always
get the data within a times with the
timestamp so um yeah
another question I think it's also
interesting because I was wondering
myself this it's if I wanted to try
stream pipes out at home do you know any
accessible iot devices to practice with
that's a good one
yeah so usually I think I personally are
not aware of any public available IRT
devices maybe some others are but for
certain protocols for example for upcua
there are some demo services online
publicly publicly available that you can
just connect them to stream pipes and
also or you use for example the
simulator that I have used in this demo
which is also included in the repository
we share here
thanks and one last is what is your
focus for further development web app or
python SDK
um
definitely both so we will in next time
work a lot on the python integration to
make that more mature and also more
feature-rich but the UI part is always a
central component of stream pipes and
will also be further developed so I
think it's definitely both yeah
okay great so let's give them one more
Applause thank you so much
all right